prosecutors are detailing an alleged
plot by a Maryland man to ram a stolen
u-haul truck into people at a popular
tourist area near the nation's mall 28
year old rondell Henry was allegedly
inspired by Isis
court documents say he stole the u-haul
with the intent of plowing it through a
crowd full of people Kris Van Cleave is
at National Harbor in Maryland were
investigators say Henry was planning to
strike Chris good morning good morning
National Harbor does have protections
against a vehicle-borne attack they've
got barriers like this all over the
place but there are still spots where
you could get a car up on the sidewalk
and that would be dangerous because look
on a busy night this area is going to be
full of people National Harbor is a
tourist attraction and a nightlife spot
according to court documents rondell
Henry harbored a hatred for non-muslims
for at least two years he'd allegedly
been watching Isis videos online
investigators say on March 26th the 28
year old stole this u-haul truck in
Virginia because his BMW wasn't big
enough to carry out an attack he drove
to Washington to Dulles Airport to
target disbelievers but arrived around
5:00 a.m. and found a few people so
instead he headed to National Harbor in
Maryland police say Henry parked the
stolen u-haul plotted an attack and
broke into a boat to hide overnight but
the next morning police found the u-haul
and arrested him people go here to enjoy
themselves have a good meal maybe do
some shopping
someone inflict that kind of pain is
ridiculous investigators say Henry was
inspired by the 2016 truck attack in
Nice France that killed 86 people he
allegedly told investigators quote I was
just going to keep driving and driving
and driving I wasn't going to stop
Prince George's County Police Chief Hank
stilinski says the key is taking every
threat seriously is there any more you
could do to make this a harder target
this is a challenge for law enforcement
across our nation how do you have a free
society and allow people to pursue their
interests without over encumbering them
with security a recent study found car
ramming terror attacks have skyrocketed
in recent years of the nearly 80 attacks
over the last four decades 30 happened
in 2017 and the FIR
four months of 2018 this was a terror
attack averted I will say that I believe
this was a potential terror attack
stopped
Henry is facing up to ten years behind
bars but so far has not been charged
with any terror related crimes he is
expected to be in court in Maryland
later today prosecutors want to keep him
locked up through the trial they're
arguing he's a flight risk
and a threat to the community Gail Chris
thank you very much